[Musique]
utilisons cette publicité pour
l'expérience
on rembobine secondes huit cent soixante
quinze mille dollars américains pour
vendre de la bière dans ce cas toute la
planète sport et la planète marketing
tourneront autour de ce stade dimanche
[Applaudissements]
et quand les uns vont se ruer aux
toilettes pendant les pauses pour les
autres c'est le moment de l'année
le plus grand moment fait tous les mâles
vont investir en début d'année pour un
con et surtout elles investissent de
plus en plus avant pour faire la
publicité de leurs publicités
tout le monde veut être en premier tout
le monde va avoir la la la première part
de marché donc plusieurs jours à
l'avance les marques vont avoir tendance
à diffuser ou dévoiler une bande annonce
de la publicité
il n'y avait qu'à voir la frénésie
autour d'une petite vidéo publiée par
l'acteur jeff bridges est une mise en
scène qui a pu faire croire à une suite
au film mythique le big lebowski
finalement autre bière autre impact bien
suis blonde
13 millions de vues en une semaine pour
vanter l'énergie éolienne utilisé par
budweiser environnement humour et
célébrités les terrains plus payant que
la politique apparemment cette année si
j'étais une marque je n'irai pas là car
il ya beaucoup de partisans derrière
beaucoup d'ennemis pas risquer d'aller
le oui côté sport le superbowl opposera
les patriots de la nouvelle angleterre
aux rams de los angeles audience 40
higuain si mathieu prost radio canada